imaginez ce que la misère et l'abjection
humaines peuvent susciter de plus
accablant imaginez les ruelles les plus
sordides les façades les plus lépreuse
les ruisseaux les plus fétide imaginer
des détritus ce innommable et dans ce
cadre des hommes des femmes des enfants
que leur gainey déguise en spectres et
si vous vouliez imaginer cela et bien
vous serez à londres en 1888 dans le
quartier de spy talent fields au nord de
whitechapel
ça n'est pas très grand spite of filth
and îlots de 400 mètres carrés
mais dès 1861 on dénombrait dans cette
île où 800 voleurs prostituées vagabond
ce n'est pas par hasard croyez moi que
dickens a conduit faglin à spy talent
fields et en 1902 jack london visitant
spitalfields sera épouvante et encore on
lui montrera une douzaine de vieilles
femmes horrible édenté et on lui dira ce
sont des prostituées oui ces femmes-là
cherchait encore le client et on lui
dira elle travaille pour deux peines ou
pour un croûton de pain rassis
voilà ce que c'était que spy dalle
fields en 1888 est justement le 31 août
1888 un portefeuille qui s'appelait
georges cros traversée whitechapel pour
se rendre à spa et alphil sindeu pas
extrêmement gay george cross parce qu'il
savait que toute la matinée ils allaient
coltiner des caisses des cageots et
surtout dans ce quartier là on n'allait
pas volontiers dans ce quartier là
et il s'avançait dans cette rue où se
trouvait un écart issoire ou ont tué des
chevaux et c'était une odeur repoussante
il faut penser à l'odeur pendant toute
cette histoire 100g à loder qui émane de
ses rues la et l'odeur des chevaux morts
voler jusqu'à lui 3h20 du matin il était
seul et tout à coup au milieu de la rue
il voit une bâche
il s'arrête il se dit mon dieu une bâche
c'est bon à prendre elle a dû tomber
d'une voiture ça se ressent une page
tous ces gens là sont très pauvres même
quand ils travaillent ils s'approchent
ça n'est pas une bâche
c'est une femme une femme allongée là
sur le pavé une femme morte
un cadavre elle baigne dans son sang
alors il ira chercher les polices man
qu'il pourra trouver les constables et
bientôt il y aura un médecin 4 heures du
matin qui viendra voir ce cadavre et il
verra que la femme a été tuée a été
égorgé d'un coup de couteau qui lui a
tranché la gorge les deux carotide
il ne verra pas plus ce médecin peu
curieux ou me up surtout pressé et ont
envie d'aller se recoucher
ce n'est que plus tard dans la journée
que portait à la morgue un autre médecin
le vent la jupe de cette femme verra
qu'elle a été éventré et c'est la
première fois que l'on va constater un
de ces crimes qui vont défrayer la
chronique pendant tant de mois pendant
tant de semelles et disons le aussi
pendant tant d'années on identifiera
cette femme
on saura qu'elle s'appelle poli nichols
qu'elle a 42 ans et nous saurons que
paul nicholls a été la première victime
de celui qu'on a appelé jacques les
menteurs
alors oui du mois d'août 1880 8 au mois
de novembre 1888 jack l'éventreur a
frappé cinq fois ci fois peut-être
il a tué uniquement les femmes toutes
ces femmes il les a égorgé d'abord
mutilé éventré ensuite et toutes ces
femmes ont été des prostituées alors il
ya un double mystère de jack l'éventreur
d'abord le mystère de son identité
nul n'a pu à l'époque identifier jack
l'éventreur
nul n'a pu leur trouver donc
l'identifier et le second mystère c'est
celui peut-être qui m'intéresse le plus
c'est celui de la permanence de sa
gloire jeu mais vouloir entre guillemets
bien sûr de sa célébrité ivo belet parce
que réfléchissons il ya eu en grande
bretagne et ailleurs dans d'autres pays
et en france en particulier des
assassins qui ont tué plus de monde que
jacques l'éventreur beaucoup plus de
gens ils ont été célèbre quelques temps
quelques semaines les puits on les a
oubliés totalement et bien comment se
fait-il qu après un siècle ou à peu près
on se souvienne tellement de jack
l'éventreur
aujourd'hui encore à londres ont fait
peur aux petits enfants en leur parlant
jack l'éventreur
aujourd'hui encore à londres dans le
quartier de spy talent fields il ne se
passe pas de jours que l'on n'ait à
montrer le trottoir où la cour où
jacques l'éventreur à exécuter l'une de
ses victimes et il y à des romans il y à
des films il y à peu près un film tous
les dix ans et puis même bien que
l'éventreur est devenu une manière de
référence souvenez vous le 2 janvier
dernier
on arrête un homme soupçonné d'avoir tué
13 femmes on l'arrête à sheffield dans
un quartier chaud
qu'est ce que dit la presse le lendemain
vous l'avez lui comme moi on vient
d'arrêter un nouveau [ __ ] l'éventreur
alors l'explication est difficile elle
n'est pas commode je crois qu'elle peut
être donner ainsi
jack l'éventreur n'êtes pas devenus
célèbres parce qu'il a tué mais par la
façon dont il a tu par le côté théâtral
qui l'a mis à tuer et aussi par la façon
dont il a annoncé qu'il avait tués
--dont il a commenté dans ces lettres
ces assassinats ses propres assassines
c'est pour cela que jacques l'éventreur
un cas un criminel à part un personnage
surgi de la nuit et qui rentre dans la
nuit qui rentre bien sûr dans la nuit de
spyker fields de whitechapel mais aussi
dans la nuit de l'histoire car je le
répète nul n'a identifié
jack l'éventreur jusqu'ici du moins
et si nous sommes si tous les deux tous
ensemble les avions tous les deux parce
que j'ai toujours l'impression que je
m'adresse un téléspectateur
si nous sommes ensemble ce soit c'est
peut-être parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
trouver au moins une piste sérieuse qui
permettent de dire qu'ils étaient
peut-être jacques les ventres alors oui
la première victime
pauli nichols 42 ans où j'ai parlé des
films à l'instant qu'on a fait sur jack
l'éventreur vous savez en général dans
ses films les victimes jack l'éventreur
sont des servantes de bas où les
figurantes de music-hall pourquoi ben
parce qu'elles sont avenants elles sont
agréables à voir c'est pas ça du tout
les victimes de jacques les montrent en
général ces femmes là ne sont pas jeunes
ces prostituées sont beaucoup plus
proches de la clocharde que de l'image
de la courtisane agréable traditionnel
pauvre poli nicole elle avait fait qu
d'une vie à peu près normale oui normal
elle s'était mariée l'avait même eu cinq
enfants bien beau jour elle avait tout
quitté le mari les enfants pourquoi bien
la boisson c'est une constante aussi
dans cette affaire toutes ces filles
toutes ces [ __ ] toutes ces
prostituées boivent brave énormément
peut-on leur jeter la pierre c'est tout
ce qu'elles ont alors là la boisson
avait conduit assez rapidement paul et
nichols dans le ruisseau sur le trottoir
et puis elle était arrivée au fond tout
au fond lorsqu'on peut faire le trottoir
ici et là mais quand on fait le trottoir
à spyker fils tu sais le font parce que
gatland ne se trompait pas ces femmes se
donner pour presque rien elle n'avait
pas de domicile vol et nichols alors
voile et elle est bien quand elle avait
4 pence et oui ce n'était pas
grand-chose 4 pence mais quand elle
avait quatre peines l'aller à l'asile au
dépôt de mendicité savez vous que dans
ce périmètre
si étroit dans ces deux quartiers il y
avait 200 asile ou dépôt de mendicité
cette épouvantable c'est assez alors
justement le soir du 30 où elle n'avait
pas les quatre pelles et on l'avait
chassé de l'asile et une de ses amies
une autre prostituée l'avait rencontré
dans la rue raspail tel film elle était
là qui marchait et elle titubait mais
oui elle titube et parce qu'elle avait
bu et l'ami lui avait dit mais pourquoi
n'es tu pas à l'asie ville état elle
avait dit bah oui j'ai voulu gagner
l'argent du lit 4 pence as tu l'as pas
gagner ben si j'ai gagné trois fois et
alors bages les bus au fur et à mesure
et alors bah maintenant je vais encore
faire un client pour gagner les quatre
peines at elle fait ce client c'est
probable mais pas dans les conditions
qu'elle envisageait parce que le client
qu'elle a rencontré bien c té ka klé
ventre alors le lendemain la presse ça
parlait de du meurtre de paul et nichols
mais vous savez si vous lisez les
journaux de cette date là vous ne
trouverez pas grand chose quelques
lignes parce que d'abord il ya beaucoup
de meurtres à cette époque là dans
londres il ne se passe pas de semaines
que l'on trouve quatre ou cinq cadavres
dans la tamise
on sait pas très bien louis viennent on
cherche pas beaucoup d'ailleurs ce n'est
pas très grave
alors la mort le meurtre d'une
prostituée dans ces quartiers là on en
parle en quelques lignes ben rien de
plus mais on va en parler tout un on va
en parler
une semaine après
le 7 septembre et pourquoi et bien parce
que ce jour-là on trouve un autre gueule
on le trouve dans une cour toujours du
même quartier à quelques dizaines de
mètres de l'endroit où est têtu et paul
nicholls et là c'est un brave homme qui
s'approche et qui voit un cas là la
halle matin la même chose mais cette
fois le tueur l'assassin a frappé avec
une violence sauvage la tête et
pratiquement séparé du trou et on le
verra on le photographie râleurs de
l'autopsié
alors oui une deuxième femme et cette
femme l'homme elle s'appelle anna
chapman et là aussi on retrace sa vie
cette femme aussi a été mariée elle a
été mariée puis il a quitté son mari et
le mari bon boulot même fait une pension
il me fait une pension jusqu en 1886 et
là il est mort alors il n'y a plus
d'argent et ça a été la même pente les
trottoirs de spike lee fields de
whitechapel l'abjection ces femmes là
n'ont pas de domicile donc elle ne se
lave pas elles sont sales elle tire
derrière elle des relents d'alcool une
odeur repoussante un visage flétri
vieilli qu est ce que c est alors vous
me dites mais alors il ya des clients
pour ces femmes là où il y en a alors
pourquoi ses clients par vis possible
peut-être aussi parce que ces femmes la
pratique les plus bas tarifs de long et
peut-être du monde alors allez chapman
elle aussi a été chassé d'un asile
elle aussi a cherché à gagner l'argent
elle est fatiguée annie chapman elle est
malade le top-6 prouvera que les
tuberculoses au dernier degré et une
amie dans la nuit la veuve coptes
la voix et lui dit mais tu devrais aller
à l'asile tu ne vas pas bien et elle a
dit mme bah non je ne vais pas bien et
on vient donner quelques pièces de
monnaie du coup de va boire une tasse de
tv ou j'ai pas mangé aujourd'hui j'ai
pas bu même une tasse de thé l onf
impôts si et puis on la parfumer les
parties elle a rencontré elle aussi
jacques les ventres le coup sectionné et
la même chose
un énorme coup de couteau dans le ventre
et cette fois-ci jacques les vendeurs
enfin on ne sait pas encore qu'il
s'appelle jacques les ventes en mai nous
l'appellerons nous appeler vantorre nous
le savons a tiré du ventre pardon il
faut bien que je le dise tout l'appareil
unique alors 2e mortes et là d'un seul
coup dans ces quartiers où explose
comment dans le même périmètre la même
chose égorgés éventrés c'est le même
assassin c'est signé mais alors il va
peut-être frappé de nouveau quand demain
après-demain la semaine prochaine on est
en danger dans le quartier et la terreur
panique se lève tôt white chapel et
spite of feeling et la police arrive et
la police cherche et on interroge
partout va dans les bouges en interroge
116 tous les suspects tout ce qui n'est
pas suspect tout ce qu'il est ils ne
trouvent pas leur traditionnellement
dans ces quartiers-là la police inutile
de vous le dire qu'on n'aime pas la
police mais cette fois elle non
seulement on a aimé on l'a méprisé on
rappelle et on rappelle que le chef de
cette police appelle search à warren
certes chaloine c'est un général un
général de l'armée coloniale et oui dans
cette époque d'expédition coloniale il a
maté assez sévèrement quelques
insurrection au delà des mais justement
parce que il a maté sévèrement ces
insurrections on l'a nommé à londres
parce qu'on estime que à londres tout ne
va pas pour le mieux dans le meilleur
des mondes et oui nous sommes dans une
période de chômage très grave de misère
affreuse
c'était le terrible hiver de 1887
elle a pour la première fois
les misères les chômeurs sont sortis
leurs quartiers de l'orgue est hors
n'était pas bien méchant ces miséreux
vous savez ce qu'il faisait bien le
dimanche 6 organisé un défilé et défilé
derrière des pancartes et sur ses
pancartes savez vous ce qu'il avait
écrit sous simplement des verset de
l'évangile disant que les riches
devaient penser aux pauvres
et alors ils allaient tourner autour des
églises dans les beaux quartiers
malheureusement et là la gentry avait le
spectacle d'une misère affreuse à
laquelle elle préférait ne pas penser
alors on a trouvé ça ce contenu ces noms
sortent charles warren le général de
l'armée coloniale on se dit voilà
l'homme de la situation
ça a été l'homme de la situation parce
que tout simplement ce joe warren a fait
d'amener contre ces miséreux a fait
donner non seulement la police mais la
troupe et il y a eu le fameux dimanche
sanglant
c'est dimanche sanglant au cours duquel
il ya elles deux 100 blessés graves très
graves et demain et puis le times il
faut lire le times le thym le lendemain
à jubiler littéralement disant bravo
qu'on recommence et l dommage qu'il n'y
ait pas eu davantage de victimes ça
l'aurait appris ça leur aurait appris
avec voilà le ton de l'époque alors
résultats soeur charles warren accéder à
la paierie bah oui faut bien qu'ils
soient récompensés mais il est devenu
l'homme le plus haï de la population
drian landrienne et par voie de
conséquence toute la presse et oui tout
la police parce que cette police
finalement ne voulait pas de mal
cette police ont le thé pas trop mal
avec elle les polices man était sorti du
peuple les constables c'était des gens
qu'on connaissait dans les quartiers et
d'un seul coup politique testo et c'est
important de savoir ça parce que cette
police est traumatisée
et au moment justement où jack
l'éventreur choisi de frapper il a
affaire à une police qui n'est pas bien
dans sa peau et ça peut aussi expliquer
un certain nombre alors d'un morte
la peur qu'ils mentent tout à coup les
rues qui se trouve vide le soir les
débits de boissons qui ne sont plus
achalandés les tenanciers qui pensent à
la faillite
les prostituées qui n'ont plus de
clients la peur la peur panique
l'époux vente
et puis un moment se passe un moment se
passe jusqu'à ce que une agence de
presse
la central news agency reçoivent une
lettre adressée aux patrons aux bosses
comme dit l'intitulé et cette lettre il
faut la connaître
parce que cette lettre révèle très
exactement le psychisme de l'assassin et
surtout cet esprit extraordinaire de
forfanterie de fanfaronnade
et puis cette humeau dramatique des
maniaques cet humour sardonique qui
plane d'airial et alors il écrit au
passé lui dit cheikh bosse je n'arrête
pas d'entendre dire que la police m'a
pris mais elle ne m'arrêtera pas de
sitôt ça me fait bien rire qu'ils aient
l'air si malins et qu'ils racontent
qu'ils sont sur ma piste
je suis contre les [ __ ] et oui contre
les [ __ ] voilà l'explication de tous
je suis contre les [ __ ] et je
n'arrêterai de l'est découdre que quand
je serai boucle est superbe
un monde où dernier boulot je n'ai pas
laissé à la dame le temps de payer
comment peuvent-ils me capturer
maintenant j'aime mon travail et je veux
recommencer
vous entendrez bientôt parler de moi et
de mes joyeux petit divertissement
le prochain boulot que je ferais je
couperai les oreilles de la dame et je
les enverrais à la police rien que pour
la rigolade n'est ce pas maintenant ils
disent que je suis un docteur ah ah
voilà la lettre traduite et tout au bas
de la lettre on pouvait lire la
signature jack de reaper jack de reaper
jack l'éventreur et on l'a su tout de
suite ce nom ce pseudonyme culte était
donné à lui-même parce que la police a
fait agrandir la lettre la police a fait
reproduire cette lettre sur tous les
murs de londres dans une gigantesque
affiche et autour de cette affiche il y
avait des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes qui s'assemblent et qui
s'agglutinaient jacques les ventres et
je cherchais tout à l'heure avec vous
justement pourquoi la gloire de jack
l'éventreur s'était poursuivie si
longtemps continuer si longtemps eh bien
je crois qu s'il y a de cela il ya ce
pseudonyme qu'il a choisi délibérément
qu'il s'est donnés à lui-même
et ça c'est peut-être une sorte de trait
de génie parce que jack l'éventreur
safran et ça nous frappent encore
aujourd'hui lors la lettre caprice
invité les gens qui reconnaître l
écriture à se faire connaître
dénoncer l'auteur de la lettre personne
de ces présents la peur toujours et
devant la carence de la police at hobbit
et de vigilance s'est créé
non white chapel spitalfields des hommes
ont décidé de patrouiller toutes les
nuits avec des bâtons des armes pour
essayer de mettre la main sur
l'éventreur et de protéger les gens du
quartier
et puis des étudiants même sont venus
d'oxford pour faire aussi des
patrouilles et voilà que la fin de
septembre
le 29 septembre une nouvelle lettre à la
police cette fois vous savez il en a
écrit beaucoup délais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup et on a même fait une étude
psychologique sur célé et cette lettre
là était très étrange le 29 septembre
cette lettre disait attention je vais
recommencer je vais opérer aux mines
aurizon mines auris est un endroit dans
le quartier le 1er ou le 2 à minuit on
sache bien sûr on va dire que des
policiers sont là mais je n'ai pas peur
des policiers
d'ailleurs il n'ya jamais de policiers
quand le tu as si maintenant jacques
l'éventreur avait l'incroyable audace
d'indiquer l'endroit le lieu l'heure
auxquels ils élèvent opérer et
d'ailleurs c'était faux c'était un piège
parce que quelques heures
havas après avoir envoyé cette lettre
est bien jacques l'éventreur tuer tuer
de nouveau et dans des conditions
incroyables
il y avait un club il y avait un club
pour travailleurs étrangers et dans la
cour de ce club est bien jacques
l'éventreur a rejoint une femme aulas
entraînée jusque là en se présentant
probablement comme clients cette femme
s'appelait elisabeth stride et le
lendemain on va retrouver son cadavre de
nouveau et ce cadavre également
étrangler la gorge sectionnée mais rien
de plus c'est le seul cadavre de jacques
la seule victime de jacques qui n'a pas
été éventrée pourquoi bien parce que
justement dans cette cour où tout le
monde va tout le monde ya tout le monde
passe
c'est incroyable
il est tué l'un vient il a été
probablement dérangé alors il a eu juste
le temps tu es mais un homme comme jack
l'éventreur
dès le moment où il n'a pas été jusqu'au
bout
dès le moment où il n'a pas ouvert les
entrailles de sa victime et bien il
n'est pas heureux
il n'est pas si j'ose dire assouvie et
il veut être à sous et c'est pourquoi
trois quarts d'heure plus tard seulement
il dû de nouveau tout près dans une
ruelle
mais comment dans une ruelle dans un
square dans une place sur une place et
sur cette place donne 3 rue et il y a
policeman qui tournent en permanence est
incroyable par ces trois rues d'étals
gens pourraient arriver à n'importe quel
moment et bien ils tuent là et cette foi
et cette fois ils éventrent sa victime
il est content il a fait ce qu'il devait
faire
et puis même il prélève un brin de la
victime et ils l'emportent et quelques
jours plus tard le président du comité
de vigilance mr losc recevra une lettre
de l'éventreur et dans cette lettre qui
est un petit paquet il y à un morceau du
rhin en question cette femme s'appelait
kate moss et c'est un morceau du rhin de
kate
qu'on envoie et la police
cela montrera aux médecins qui diront
c'est bien le rein de la dernière
victime de l'éventreur et dans la lettre
y aura ce passage faut le site est tout
de même dans la lettre il y aura ce
passage je ne vous en envoie qu'un
morceau parce que le reste je les fait
frire et je les mange et c'était très
bon nous avons évidemment à faire à un
homme atteint de folie homicide
mais ce sont ces gens là qui sont
dangereux parce que l'intelligence ne
disparaît pas dans la folie homicide
alors là cette fois c'est le comble de
la terreur jamais jamais jamais la pearl
épouvante n'a régné tout autant et la
police toujours impuissante qui
enquêtent recherche qui interroge dans
les bouges qui interroge dans les deux
sens dépôt de mendicité et asile
qui passe tout au peigne fin et les
groupes du comité de vigilance et les
étudiants d'oxford
rien rien rien rien et puis une semaine
une autre semaine rien trois semaines un
mois
on commence à respirer peut-être que cet
homme-là a renoncé lé parti qui sait que
lui est il arrivé
c'est fini le cauchemar et le 9 novembre
on pense à tout autre chose parce que le
9 novembre et bien c'est l'anniversaire
du prince de galles le futur edouard 7
le fils de la reine victoria
et puis c'est aussi le jour de l'entrée
solennelle du lanmeur de londres vous
savez que chaque année il y à l'entrée
solennelle de leur maire de londres
alors c'est une occasion pour la foule
ce sont des plaisirs gratuit des
plaisirs qui ne coûte rien la foule se
masse là pour crier vive leur mère il ya
des chevaux
il y à des poses uniforme il ya le
garros pleins de glace de leur mère qui
est là dedans derrière ces glaces texan
d'hermine ça plaît beaucoup aux pauvres
gens et on est là pour acclamer leur
mère puis voilà le lot revers qui passe
vive leur mère et tout à coup dans cette
ville des crieurs de jaune et qui crie
est lasse des choses déjà connu des
phrases connu jack l'éventreur est
revenue nouveau crime de jack
l'éventreur et oui il a tué il a tué
deux nouveau et cette fois son crime est
abominable plus abominables que jamais
la femme qui l'a tué pour une fois n'est
pas une vieille femme flétri horrible
aux cheveux gris repoussant
c'est une prostituée bien sûr mais celle
ci est jolie et puis elle a 25 ans elle
ne traîne pas dans les dépôts de
mendicité
elle a un domicile à melen scott lynch
en est justement grâce à des témoignages
on la suit à la trace
cette femme là d'abord on sait qui elle
est là aussi elle a commencé par une vie
normale c'est maria 16 ans avec un
mineur les pires landaise et les quatre
lits et puis le mari est mort un an et
demi après le mariage dans un accident
de la mine et la compagnie a mis 18 mois
à lui verser la première mensualité de
la petite pension à laquelle elle avait
droit dix-huit mois elle n'avait pas de
famille elle n'avait rien pas de travail
le dénuement le plus total elle est
tombée elle a sombré
il a commencé à se prostituer à cardiff
et ensuite à londres
et puis elle est tombée dans ce quartier
meridj and kelly
voilà cent ans voilà la dernière victime
de jack l'éventreur et on sait on sait
que on l'a rencontré dans la nuit se
promenant dans le quartier cherchant des
clients on l'a vu dans dpup dans
plusieurs pubs
elle entrait buvait un petit verre et
puis elle cherche un client dans ce pub
n'en trouvait pas et puis vint un peu
avant minuit une femme l'a vu et l'a vu
avec un homme c'est la première fois il
ya des descriptions d'hommes qui ont
abordé les précédentes victimes mais
vagues mais quand même une constante un
homme de 35 ans à peu près on parle de
sa corpulence on a parlé d'un bagage
qu'il portait une casquette de chasse
et cette fois c'est un homme de ce genre
là 38 ans dit le témoin corpulent et il
sort d'un pub avec marie-jeanne kelly et
plus tard dans la nuit
un autre témoin heart out une semaine un
ancien veilleur de nuit voix mary jane
kelly pénétrait dans miller's courte
elle va accéder à sa chance et il la
voit avec un homme est ce le même ou en
la tête changé entre temps une ou deux
heures se sont passées
celui ci lui voit un manteau avec des
garnitures dastrac quand ils y voient
des guêtres et sans doute que le manteau
est ouvert parce qu'ils voient assez
distinctement qu'une chaîne en or bar la
poitrine de 7,1 et chose curieuse le
premier témoin une femme avait dit une
moustache aussi et lui une chine se dit
également une moustache une moustache
ancre au pitch hinson s'éloigne et c'est
le lendemain matin à 10 heures que le
propriétaire de l'immeuble se rendant
compte que marriage and kelly n'a pas
payé son loyer envois sont commis pour
le lui réclame et le commis frappe à la
porte de mary jane kelly on sait qu'elle
est là on l'a vu entrer et puis en
rapporte alors on peut on peut en
montant sur une poubelle c'est au rez de
chaussée de cette chambre on peut en
montant sur une poubelle par le vasistas
apercevoir la chambre c'est ce que fait
le commis et alors là tout à coup c'est
un terrible et hurlements
quand en tout la cour d'un seul coup
tout le monde et aux fenêtres coiffe
wilko mis à hurler et il dira ce que
j'ai vu c'est l'oeuvre d'un démon c'est
pas l'oeuvre d'alain et un peu plus tard
quand la police viendra quand les
médecins viendront dans la chambre ce
qu'ils verront sera proprement
hallucinant
jamais l'homme ne s'est acharné autant
jamais jack l'éventreur deux sets
acharnés aussi sauvagement bien sûr il
était tranquille il était dans cette
chambre
jusqu'ici il a toujours opéré en plein
air mais il avait tout son temps alors
si j'ose dire il s'en est donné à coeur
joie
d'abord la la tête est encore totalement
sectionné et puis il a ouvert deux hôtes
en bas le corps et il a rangé sur une
table avec une sorte de symétrie
artistique les organes de cette
malheureuse marival qu'il a placé les
reins il a placé les saints la place
elle que requiert tout le reste vive et
des clous au mur de la chambre sans
doute que le précédent locataire avait
des gravures ou des tableaux alors il a
attaché des lambeaux de chair assez vous
était bobo table et à bobino voilà ce
qu'on a vu alors de nouveau la terreur
de nouveau la panique et le journaux qui
se déchaîne et la police qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait la police il faut que ça
charles warren démissionne il
démissionne bien sûr et puis la reine
victoria de son château de balmoral qui
intervient qui écrit à son premier
ministre lors salisbury qui lui dit mais
enfin qu'est ce que fait la police
il faut réorganiser la police il faut
éclairer les rues ça n'est pas possible
vous m'aviez promis d'en parler à vos
collègues du ministère et laure
salisbury réunis en conseil des
ministres tout exprès pour décider des
mesures à prendre
alors on en voit encore un peu plus de
police dans white chapel et on trouve
toujours pas et on trouve pas et les
semaines passent je dis bien les
semaines c'est bien qu'il s'était écoulé
près d'un mois depuis le dernier crime
alors pendant un mois aux trembles
tremble jusqu'à la fin de l'année 1888
et imaginez que vous êtes un habitant de
ces quartiers là tout à coup vous voyez
au début 2008 189 s'est tenue et
d'agents de police cette nuée de police
semaines de casting
vous les voyez partie et oui souvent il
ya un ordre a été donné au sommet c'est
fini on retire la police
on retire les renforts au retire tout
alors il ne reste plus que le comité de
vigilance et les étudiants d'oxford
les étudiants d'oxford partir au mois de
février c'est dire on peut pas passer
notre vie là on a des études à fait
puis si la police est partie pourquoi ne
pas retirer temps passe et le comité de
vigilance se réunit et se dit mais on
nous laisse seuls avec nous mêmes nous
laisse en proie à jack l'éventreur parce
que c'est sûr jacques l'éventreur va
revenir et il y à un membre du comité de
vigilance qui s'appelle alberte baptême
il va se rendre à scotland yard et qui
va voir des policiers et qui veulent à
vous dire vous n'aviez pas le droit de
faire ça pourquoi avez vous retirer vous
renfort pourquoi avez vous retiré
oiseaux c'est effrayant vous laisser nos
quartiers libres pour que jack
l'éventreur frappe
on lui répond un cocktail ou capable de
prêter un serment de vous y tenir
ah oui dit pas car pourquoi je ne
passerais pas serment mais alors juré de
laurier et le journal aurait dit bon
voilà vous n'avez plus avoir peur et
pourquoi il est mort qui aimons jacques
les ventres quoique très venteux
vraiment oui les morts nous avons
repêché son cadavre dans la tamise
mais qui s assemblent peux pas vous le
dire nous savons que c'est lui nous
savons que nous l'avons repêché mais par
égard pour sa famille nous ne pouvons
pas donne talent et son identité
enfin écoutez il faut le dire du bac at
il faut rassurer non on ne peut pas vous
en dire davantage et maintenant vous ne
parlez pas vous avez prêté serment et
voilà que ma crainte est fou furieux
il m'écoutait si jamais en tout cas mon
serment à balayer je dirais tout et vous
serez ridicule et on vous insultera et
on vous détesterez encore un peu plus
comme vous voulez 10 des policiers nous
nous sommes sûrs de l'autre ainsi pour
la police en janvier 1889 ont déçu que
jack l'éventreur est mort qu'il s'est
suicidé qu'il s'est donné la mort et
qu'on a même repêcher son canard c'est
une chose dont il faut que vous vous
souveniez justement pour la clarté
peut-être des explications que je serai
amené à donner tout talent
et c'est la police qui a raison et c'est
le comité de vigilance qui a tort ce
pauvre albert jakarta eu tort de se
montrer si furieux parce qu'on lève jack
l'éventreur ne reviendra jamais il s'est
littéralement évanoui
mais non là on peut poser une question
pourquoi scotland yard
n'at-il pas dit la vérité parce que ce
silence sur l'identité et sur le destin
de jack l'éventreur et gravé semble
inexplicable pour rassurer ces
populations il fallait dire la vérité on
l'a pas dit dès le moment où on gardait
le silence c'était ouvrir la voie à
toutes les suppositions s'était laissé
les imaginations les plus folles se
déchaîner s'était exposé l'opinion à
tous croire tout entendre tout admettre
et c'est bien ce qui s'est passé alors
pourquoi
question pourquoi la police deux langues
n'at-elle rien dit alors que semble-t-il
la police de londres savait alors oui je
dis les choses les plus folles choses
les plus incroyables
la première hypothèse la plus inattendue
a été formulée par un jeune écrivain qui
était médecin kiné publié un livre son
premier livre sherlock holmes et cet
écrivain s'appelait arthur conan doyle
et savez vous comment ils expliquaient
l'a fait ils disent eh bien voilà il
n'ya qu'une possibilité c'est que
jacques les montreurs étaient déguisés
en femmes parce que sans cela il
n'aurait pas pu aborder ces femmes aussi
facilement et le déguisement femme lui
permettait de s'en fuir puisque la
police cherchait un nom c'est ingénieux
mais ça ne tient pas parce que il disait
ce conan doyle se disait seule une femme
pouvait aborder ces femmes il oublié que
ces femmes étaient des prostituées et
que leur métier au contraire voulait que
des hommes les à bord desquels
rechercher ses hommes mais l'idée
l'hypothèse de condom en dieu a fait du
chemin et en 1934 encore on l'a publié
tout un livre pour soutenir on allait
plus loin on disait pas qu'ils étaient
déguisés en femmes on disait que c'était
une sahraouie hypothèse c'est une femme
est même l'auteur de cette hypothèse
beaucoup d'ingéniosité pour quid
imagination disait c'est sûrement une
sasha
oui parce que ces prostituées avaient
souvent à faire en fessionnels mans
assez sages femmes qui étaient des
avorteuse bien sûr est l'auteur de cette
hypothèse allait même plus loin il
disait certainement l'une des
prostituées a dénoncé la sage femme
on l'a mise en prison et en prison la
sage pam a décidé de se venger non
seulement de la prostituée qui l'avait
dénoncé mais aussi de toutes les
collègues de cette prostituée savez bien
sûr on peut tout imaginer napoléon
disait quelque chose qui résume tout il
disait avec des si on met paris dans une
armée paris dans une bouteille oui bien
sûr bien là aussi on n'a pas d'arguments
on n'a pas de preuves on n'a même pas de
présomption pur produit de l'esprit
c'est un jeu de l'esprit alors cessons
de rêver mais george bernard shaw est
également entré en scène le fameux
humoriste était à ses débuts mais il
était déjà george bernard shaw
alors il a dit c'est qu'à l'époque show
était social-démocrate c'était un homme
qui avait des idées de gauche très sa
selle et il a dit il faut remercier
jacques les ventres parce que cette
misère affreuse qui règne dans ces
quartiers personnes en bas les sociaux
démocrates essayer d'en entendent
attirer l'attention sur ces horreurs les
écoutez pas il a suffi que j'appelais
ventre heures paraissent qu'il exécute
cinq prostituées tout à coup les
journaux les plus conservateurs on
parlait de cette horrible misère et on a
commencé à faire quelque chose et c'est
exact que des souscriptions été ouverte
on a apporté des secours à ces gens et
même on l'a décidé de raser les taudis
d'élever la des immeubles à loyers
limiter ça a quelque peu changé pour ces
gens là ce qui fait que george bernard
shaw admirable maurice tu écrivais
froidement jack l'éventreur est un
réformateur social jean bon sur yon à
lyon
essayons plutôt d'interroger les
policiers parce que
les policiers ont su et même s'ils n'ont
pas parlé ouvertement on peut supposer
qu'ils ont parlé au sein de leurs
familles alors interrogeant les familles
ont là et notamment on a interrogé la
famille de surf charleroi c'est
l'écrivain américain tom cullen l'auteur
de l'anc est la plus parfaite sur cette
affaire qui a procédé à ses
interrogateurs et on ainsi que serge
charles warren penser qu'il s'agissait
d'un maniaque sexuel ce qui est évident
mais disait aussi à ses proches qu'il
s'était suicidé après le dernier meurtre
celui de mary jane kelly et que on avait
retrouvé son corps et que cet homme là
c'était donc pratiquement le même donc
parler les policiers aalberg paca c'est
intéressant
un autre policier à l'inspecteur lui
s'est garé en parlant d'un certain jan
chapman qui avait empoisonné
successivement ces trois femmes qui
avaient été pendus et il pensait que
chapman était également l'éventreur ce
n'est pas envisageable parce que d'abord
n'y a aucune preuve mais ensuite les
criminologie ce tu disais ils étayent
leur démonstration sur quantité
l'observation que les empoisonneurs
répugne toujours aux crimes de sang ne
peut pas être les deux donc il faut
éliminer l'hypothèse d'or chapman
de même il yal qui est monté sur les
chefs feront également parce qu'il avait
tué qui a dit c'est moi
jack l'éventreur s'appelait 10 lits
alors c'est intéressant qu'il ait dit
c'est moi jacques l'éventreur mais il
l'a dit au moment d'être pendu il a
d'ailleurs été pendus sur le champ il
pensait probablement pouvoir retarder
son exécution l'hypothèse ne tient pas
parce que pendant tout l'automne 1888
cet homme là était en prison tant qu'ils
ne pouvaient pas opérer alors tout cela
il faut l'éliminer je vous passe un
certain nombre d'hypothèses beaucoup
d'hypothèses des dizaines et centaines
d' hypothèse
vous ne pouvez savoir à quel point on
l'a formulé l'hypothèse d'explications
sur jacques les ventres
qu'est ce tu as continué longtemps
longtemps longtemps en 1929 paraît à
nouveau et cet ouvrage attire
l'attention d'un très large public et de
la presse parce que l'auteur déclare je
sais la vérité je sais qui est jacques
les ventres et que raconte ceci en 1886
vivait à londres à m il ne donne pas le
nom du médecin parce que la famille
existe toujours et ce médecin il dit je
l'appellerai stan ce médecin avait un
fils jeune fils adolescent
et ce fils s'est rendu dans ces
quartiers mal famés où l'on trouvait des
prostituées à bon marché
il a rencontré marie jeanne kelly et
elle lui a communiqué la syphilis et la
syphilis qu'on soignait très mal à cette
époque qu'a fait des ravages foudroyant
en quelques mois le jeune homme est mort
et en 1888 quand il est mort le père le
docteur stanley a décidé de venger son
fils c'est alors qu'il s'est enfoncé
dans lé quartier de whitechapel de
spyker fields et que là il a interrogé
les prostituées
il cherchait mary jane qu'elle est et
chaque fois qu'une prostituée lui parler
lui donner un renseignement bien pour ne
pas qu'elle puisse à son tour le
dénoncer il est tué
élégant et ainsi il a égorgé
successivement quatre femmes avant
d'arriver à la cinquième qui était bien
marichelles kelly
alors là il l'a suivi dans sa chambre et
là enfin heureux avec une joie démesurée
il a tué dans les conditions que vous
avez il a littéralement dépecé ce
malheureux corps et disait l'auteur de
cette hypothèse de cette explication
plus tôt
vous voyez c'est bien l'homme qui est
arrivé à son but les autres il les a
égorgé les a éventré mais celle-ci il
s'acharne sur elle et ensuite ce médecin
c'est considéré comme satisfait il s'est
expatrié parti pour l'amérique du sud
s'est installé à buenos aires
et là il est mort à buenos aires mais
avant de mourir il s'est confié à ses
confrères médecins essaient de ce
confrère médecins que l'homme qui
écrivait que le journaliste qui publiait
16 disait tenir la vérité vous êtes
cette histoire où la crue est même
aujourd'hui il ya quelques jours alors
qu'on savait que je préparais cette
émission l'admets ami m'a dit ah oui
c'est l'histoire de ce médecin qui est
oui on en parle encore on le croit
encore on atteint on a tort parce que
l'histoire est entièrement inventée et
c'est le meilleur spécialiste français
de jack l'éventreur monsieur bernard
houdin qui a tué définitivement cette
histoire pour lui il s'agit d'un roman
le journaliste qui a publié cette
affaire l'a publiée comme un roman rien
de plus et pourquoi est ce un roman est
bien d'abord parce que même à cette
époque là la syphilis ne tuez pas en
quelques mois il fallait souvent disant
vatan et puis on a fait le top 6 de mary
chain kelly on n'a trouvé aucune trace
de maladie vénérienne et cela suffirait
à couper court à cette légende si
également l'on ne trouvait aucune trace
à l'époque considéré de médecins
britanniques morand à buenos aires alors
on en parle en plus dans tout cela était
assez décevant et on pouvait se dire on
ne connaîtra jamais la vérité sur jack
l'éventreur
et puis 40 ans ont passé et puis on
s'est trouvé en présence de pistes
nouvelles et dix ans le bien
intéressante en 1860 1960 10 un médecin
le docteur stowell publie dans une revue
britannique the criminal gist à l'arc et
déclare je sais qui est jacques les
ventes
et pourtant il ne donne pas son nom il
ne peut pas le donner il déclare je ne
peux pas ne pas le droit de le donner et
ce coupable il va le désigner par s la
lettre s et cody t il dit que s
appartient à une famille située au
sommet de la hiérarchie sociale en
anglais que les parents devaient son été
respectée de tous les anglais et que la
grand-mère de s a été vénéré par tous
les angles il dit que ce s a fait de
grands voyages en mer etc à 16 ans sur
un bateau il a eu la révélation de
tendances homosexuelles et avec un marin
il a gagné si j'ose dire la syphilis et
en rentrant en angleterre on l'a fait
soigner par un médecin de grand renom
soeurs williams gueule qui n'a pu rien
faire et se soeurs williams gal a pu
constater simplement que la maladie
progresser progresser et bientôt l'homme
s a été atteint de folie homicide et
bientôt s s'est enfoncé dans les
quartiers que nous connaissons a
recommencé à égorger et a éventré et
prostituent
la police l'a arrêté après le meurtre de
kate et l'os elle l'a reconnu et quand
elle a su qu'ils étaient s
elle a été épouvanté pas question
d'ouvrir une instruction pas question de
faire un procès public
alors heureusement les médecins étaient
formels cet homme était fou alors dans
un asile immédiatement et on la terre et
il arrivera à s'évader de cette thèse
et il pourra commettre à dernier meurtre
sur la personne de la malheureuse mary
jane kelly alors on le cravate encore
une fois on l'arrête et cette fois il
est dans l'asile et là on le surveillent
jour et nuit
ils ne voient plus en sortir et
d'ailleurs les six malades si gravement
malade qu'il m'aura deux mois plus tôt
voilà voilà le récit de dr store qui
ajoute qu'ils ajoutent que les parents
de s posséder des grandes chasses en
écosse et que la s avait appris à
dépasser les chevreuils et les serres ce
qui lui avait donné une certaine
initiation pour éventrer et dépeçait ses
victimes
alors évidemment toute la grande presse
britannique a repris l'article de dr
stowell on est allé le trouver on lui a
dit mais enfin est ce qui s docteur je
ne peux pas le dire
je peux simplement vous dire que ce
n'est pas la reine victoria ni sa
sainteté le pape
le docteur troll été à ce jour un
humoriste mais on a commencé à
rapprocher les détails et on s'est dit
en face aux mets de lier par an
respectée par tous les anglais la
grand-mère vénéré par tous les angles
mais c'est la famille royale la grand
mère la reine victoria il n'y a pas
cette époque d'autres femmes que les
anglais venaient alors qui est le petit
fils et on l'a trouvé c'est le fils du
prince de galles le film le fils du
futur edouard 7 c'est le duc de clarence
et il est exact on le sait que le duc de
clarence était un homosexuel notoire et
même la police au coude raf l'avait
découvert dans une maison spéciale
réservée aux homosexuels
déjà il y avait eu scandale qu'on
l'avait étouffé et on savait en effet
qu'il chassait on savait qu'ils dépecé
les serres et les chevreuils et puis
même un des témoins dans white chapel
avait dit que l'homme qu'ils avaient
entrevu portait une casquette de chasse
une de ses casquettes de chasse comme le
duc de clarence emporté alors la presse
à cette époque s'est dit mais alors
celui du bio plantes hypothèse
intéressante mais totalement fausses
pourquoi bien parce que d'abord le 9
novembre 1888 le duc de clarence n'est
pas allons il ne peut pas tuer marriage
and kelly
il est en train de célébrer
l'anniversaire de son père le prince de
galles à 100 d'un gars et puis enfin on
nous dit s a été internée dans un asile
dont il n'est pas sorti où il est mort
deux mois plus tard
tous les doubles de clarensac continue à
vivre au grand jour il a participé à la
vie de la cour
on voit son nom dans tous les bulletins
de la cour et même il va se fiancer avec
marie de tête grande fiançailles
officielles
il va se marier et les années ont passé
et il est apte en 1892 quatre ans plus
tard il est toujours en vie n'est pas du
tout interne et d'une pneumonie il meurt
et mari de teck sa fiancée posant
d'ailleurs son frère le futur george st
ça ne peut pas être le duc de clarence
et pourtant je vous parlais de piste
intéressante il faut maintenant parler
du d'autres pistes
un policier soeur melville mcnabb a
fermé le dossier en 1892 entre
parenthèses la loi anglaise veut que les
dossiers fermés depuis s'être ouvert
qu'un siècle plus tard c'est donc en
1992 qu'on ouvrira le dossier jack
l'éventreur m'élever le max nagl a connu
sa hausse et longtemps il n'a rien dit
mais sa fille en 1959 à publier les
notes personnelles qu'il avait conservée
et soeurs melville max nagl déclare la
scotland yard a su que le suspect ne
pouvait se situer entre 3
le premier c'est un juif polonais rendu
fou par la pratique du vie solitaire ça
ce sont des constatations de l'époque le
second c'est un médecin russe des
magnans éliminons l'année l'autre
déclare soeur melville mcknight le
troisième s'appelle montegut jones croft
et on sait qui c'est il appartient une
excellente famille il a grandi dans un
manoir il a fait de brillantes études à
oxford il est devenu avocat
malheureusement les clients ne sont pas
venus il a dû se résoudre à se faire
professeur adjoint dans un collège on le
voit pour la dernière fois au début de
décembre 1888 et on retrouve son cadavre
dans la tamise le 31 décembre 1881
c'est intéressant parce qu'il avait un
domicile allons à quelques minutes de
nos quartiers à quelques minutes des
lieux où on avait assassiné jack
l'éventreur à opérer et soeurs melville
maintenat gagnent dans ses notes d'éclat
la famille était au courant important
parce que quelques jours après le
suicide de montaigu john kruyt sa mère
entre dans un asile d'aliénés où elle
meurt deux mois plus d'un alors oui cela
ressemble c'est bien ce que la police
avait dit à l'époque
halberg bacquaert c'est bien ce que
disait sartre charles warren alors est
ce que c'est ça est-ce que c'est lui
jack l'éventreur
on l'a cru et on a peut-être eu raison
de le croire mais en 1976 par est un
nouvel ouvrage
cet ouvrage il est dû à un certain
stephen nice et ce livre s'appelle jack
de reaper de finale selon jack
l'éventreur la solution finale mais s'il
dit la solution finale il en est sûr oui
il en est sûr
et qu'est ce que raconte stephen nice et
bien cette histoire qui est
extraordinaire et qu'il faut connaître
en tant qu il la tient cette histoire de
joseph ces craintes qui lui même le fils
d'un patron qui a joui d'un certain
renom au début du siècle à la fin du
siècle dernier walters sic
qu'est ce qu'a raconté walter ses cartes
à son fils ce peintre en 1884 avaient
été amenés à donner des leçons de dessin
au duc de classe le voilà qui revient le
deal de classe alors une fois par
semaine le duc de clarence se rendait
dans l'atelier de walter ses cartes et
là tout à coup un jour il rencontre un
jeune modèle une jeune fille qui
s'appelait anne micro et là les
tendances homosexuelles du duc de
clarence vole en éclats
balayés et ils tombent sur le chant
amoureux d'un écrou que mais à l'amour
violent sans exemple à ce point qu'ils
demandent sam et qu'ils vont se marier
secrètement devant un prêtre catho
l'héritier du trône d'angleterre qui
sera naître le chef de la religion
anglicane
oui ce mari devant un prêtre hôtel et
ils ont une fille qu'il baptise alice et
ils sont 13 heures comment la reine
victor at elle appris cette affaire on
ne le sait pas mais l'abri et sa fureur
s'est déchaîné et elle a demandé à son
premier ministre à ceux qui
l'entouraient je ne veux plus entendre
parler de cette affaire
elle n'a pas donné d'instructions
précises vous savez dans ces affaires là
les gens qui sont tout à fait en eau ne
donne pas d'instruction précis c'est aux
autres d'agir et d'interpréter l'ordre
compte et on a interprète et alors est
intervenu soeurs williams gueule le
médecin while the wall encore qui
revient alors qu'est ce qu'on a fait et
bien on a conduit de force le duc de
clarence à buckingham
on lui a interdit de sortie année croque
la malheureuse est bien on l'a enlevé on
l'a conduit soeur chez soeurs williams
gal qui immédiatement décrété qu'elle
était folle on l'a internée dans un
asile d'aliénés dont elle n'est plus
jamais sortis et où elle est morte et
l'enfant réalise bien alice on l'a
confié walter sicut bon tout était pour
le mieux dans le meilleur des mondes
pas du tout parce que alice à un moment
donné à l'iss un moment où le duc de
clarence et amis crooks voyez poursuivi
il était inquiet il l'avait confié cette
petite alice à une jeune irlandaise en
qui j'avais confiance et cette
irlandaise s'appelait marie jane kelly
mary jane kelly vous entendez alors on
l'avait repris plus tard alice a
marriage and aliens n'était pas encore
constitué à ce moment là mais quelques
mois plus tard le dénuement personne ne
s'occupe les plaies des l'ailé
elle a fait le trottoir et dans le
quartier de spy talent field elle a
commencé à parler à ses compagnes un
échappement l'autre elisabeth olinicoff
vous les connaissez elle leur a parlé de
cet enfant elle a dit que c'était
l'enfant du duc de clarence et ces
femmes qui était si pauvre ce sentier
bien on peut gagner de l'argent on va
faire chanter la famille royale et il y
a eu un début du chantage et de nouveau
tout temps on a dit arrête pas d'ordre
précis mais arrêter ça et on a arrêté sa
et comment 3 à walter six soeurs
williams gueule et le cocher du duc de
clarence est un acte qui à chaque fois
ça s'est passé de la même manière
sickert racoler une de ces femmes
l'amener aux cavs qui attendait dans
l'obscurité
là le cocher étranglé la femme et le
médecin avec son scalpel s'en donner à
coeur joie pour faire croire un crime
sadique y en a une de trop kate à la
hausse elle n'avait rien fait mais la
tuer par heure voilà c'était fini la
vengeance était accomplie et voilà ce
qu'a raconté walter six cartes à son
fils en 1942 à son lit noir en ajoutant
un détail c'est que la petite alice
qu'on lui avait confié bien il avait
épousé que joseph son fils était dans le
fils d'ali j'aurais voulu être à la
place de joseph ses cartes
j'aurais voulu savoir où bien j'aurais
dû ou voulu être à côté de savoir
comment il a réagi en apprenant qu'il
était à la fois le descendant de jack
l'éventreur et d'edouard sel alors le
livre a paru ça fait un bruit énorme et
un ce moment là joseph sika a démenti il
a dit que n'ont eu que stands et nice
s'était mépris qu'il n'avait jamais dit
ça je trouve le démenti un peu tardif
parce qu'ils savaient que ce livre
allait être écrit il avait assisté à la
composition du livre et pourquoi où ils
étaient épouvantés par le bruit qu'on
faisait autour de lui mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il faille attaché beaucoup
d'importance à ces du menti alors quoi
là
do this faire le point terminant c'est
une tâche difficile mais nous allons
essayer
il faut éliminer toutes les autres
thèses à mon sens il n'y a que deux
thèses pose est celle de montaigu john
bryant et il y a énormément de points
positifs qui militent en faveur de cette
thèse et puis il y à la thèse dernière
de walter si kurt qui était très
attachant presque convaincante alors la
terre laquelle des deux vous avez
entendu ces têtes je vous donne ma
parole que vous êtes en possession des
éléments du dossier je vous ai presque
tout dit alors vous pouvez maintenant
jugée comme on dit en votre âme et
conscience et l'historien l'historien
que je suis et bien honnêtement
l'historien que je suis ne sais pas il
attendra si dieu lui près de vie 1992
époque à laquelle on ouvrira le dossier
et où l'on saura s'il y avait trois jack
l'éventreur ou à 7
[Musique]